go online let's see if the go live works
now it says I'm live
all right give it a minute all right now
it says I'm live
I don't see anything else give it a
second give it a second it's giving me
the [__] to bit rate error stuff but
yeah all right
uh Guys YouTube coming for the kids back
at it again back at it again give me a
second get things but again uh what's
going on y'all Yeah man they coming for
the Lords they're coming for us they
want us to be great today before we go
King you need to get your thing up just
so we know we got this yeah well let's
let them get this boss yeah
and then we'll get the um what you call
it all right cool once if YouTube goes
down down before that hey we gotta deal
with it man it is what it is but a king
So now that we got our thoughts here
like on this uh where you at man you
know as far as the big black and because
of cloud not because of Call of Duty
well it seems like somebody took that
afternoon and watched Minority Report
and watch uh Terminator and ran back and
said this is the basis of what this is
like it's like oh my gosh I'll talk to
you later all right bro it looks like
somebody sat there and said you know
what
I'm gonna watch all of the uh Jedi Saga
and Anakin becomes uh Darth Vader
we should we should listen to everybody
in the beginning and don't don't don't
take Anakin no he's going he's going to
bring the worst catastrophes
yo
they was first screaming about Call of
Duty what I like about the PlayStation
dudes I'm gonna make it about y'all
first I can't because y'all are some
creatures uh
y'all hide your little hoes while a war
is going on
you got a little fake generals poke your
heads out just to see if I'm still on
the battlefield knocking people's teeth
loose
and I'm gonna tell you that this deal is
gonna go through all right I'm not at it
I don't sit here and say no 10 no 15
percent I'm standing on it it's money
right there I don't give up I'm not that
dude that you're you're knocked down and
I'll be like you got it you got it no
imma trip you imma throw dirt in your
face I'ma grab you on the floor and I'm
gonna poke your eyeballs out you're
gonna get this work right so at no time
and I believe Microsoft is like me
um
you should have been wave your little
white flag y'all y'all waved the White
Flag as soon as they said they was
acquiring them I was already I don't
like Call of Duty that's that was you
waving your white flag I don't even play
Call of Duty anyway
y'all got punched in your mouth and was
like
it's over it's over
listen man until they say that there's
absolutely no way Phil Dominus Maximus
are really expenses on your head
like this ain't over nobody got to their
position by giving up shout out to
Patrick who got rejected two times
before he put in and submitted for his
application to get the job that he
wanted
nothing that you want in this life is
gonna be easy you thought it was gonna
be easy getting this done nah it's gonna
be fights you're gonna have to give out
contracts you're gonna have to do this
so being the fact that they set you up
gave you a list of people to go out to
you wouldn't hit everybody on that list
with Call of Duty 10-year plans
then you're gonna come out the bus well
you know if it's another military
service game
it might be something that's detrimental
to the progress and growth in this space
and I got that voice because
isn't it strange that
Miss Khan a couple of days before goes
and sits with the CMA oh oh okay it was
four it was four Dudes it's four Dudes
that information I share some of the
information that they get to the
information they was they was ten toes
down yo Wednesday the deal is gonna go
through X Y and Z right Xbox dudes is
popping their bottles beforehand Xbox is
playing in shows true
talking about you know we got our
pom-poms up the deal is done
[Music]
I don't care anyway because I I don't
even play so you apply dudes as Friday
because they knew it was over they
thought it was exactly they thought the
fight was over they thought that Mike
Tyson knockout you know
Rob Fury and fury went down he was like
yeah it's over the fight's over
but he got up
he got up he was like
hmm oh my god
oh my god dude try to act like they
ain't kidding
none of these dudes cared about Call of
Duty at all it was like I don't care
about that I don't even play that if you
look at my timeline I play moment mostly
you know Square Enix
you feel safe about your life you know I
I'm looking for Final Fantasy
are you inside those are the same dudes
that care about the industry all of a
sudden now yo oh man you know in case we
gotta pay the devs you know because if
Call of Duty go over there it's gonna be
a Game Pass and the devs ain't gonna get
paid shut up
uh and all of a sudden CMA makes a
turnaround oh
four Dudes that I trust with that
information because I can verify most of
the information though
had it trending that way yeah that the
deal is going to go through what
happened from point A to point B who
said what to what who owes what homie
favor deal what money changed hands and
went someplace else to come back with uh
infrastructure that is in its infancy to
be the reason for the block
and you and what you're saying is Well
Microsoft is is is prevalent in this
space and it will control the space
Microsoft so they give the game to
anybody they don't care about that that
was not it and if you need any help in
this space Microsoft went out to help uh
Sony they needed Azure Cloud Server that
that was before this deal yeah like your
homie your legs ain't looking right you
know I got some I'll teach you how to
start you know what I'm saying I'll show
you some leg presses y'all need to do it
in the Jailer Jim that just works on up
above oh don't say my man top heavy come
on
Kratos can't jump
oh my God and Microsoft was like yo B I
got you on them legs I help you out you
calling Sony Johnny Bravo over here
[Laughter]
looking like a martini glass oh man
Sony was like yeah I'll give you some um
pre-workout it was like yeah all right
cool that's what's up hey guys okay give
me some Advanced GG we good
Microsoft has been willing to help the
whole time so for you to say in this
space that they went this way no this is
a delay tactic because if you haven't
noticed Sony been during this
acquiring this
acquiring boom bar videos
but the thing with boom bar is this Cody
brought him in to do a game Saw how they
worked it was like let's buy them before
they make anything so the FTC and the
CMA and anybody can't say that these
dudes was an established entity
we purchased them when they didn't have
anything so Sony is doing it smart going
around acquiring enough Dodge stuff here
and there and building that stable so
when they can get to their online games
and they can complete compete this is a
delay tactic problem is
let's just say Microsoft says and they
win with the EU it went with the FTC so
he was going to be keto is looking right
but let's say it's looking like
Transformers optimistic shot somebody
better open up the Matrix
there will always be a Rodimus Prime
there will always be a situation that's
going to get us to the win
you're gonna get to that win right and
they're gonna do it because I'm not
giving up until it's over you know I was
part of You Got The Touch I was part of
that generation My Generation don't quit
we don't bet we don't fall we don't
break
[Music]
right so you see how attic says oh I
want I want whatever's the easiest
my generation is whatever's the hardest
because it's gonna stay longer battle
proven battle tested right
[Music]
since you've been so difficult
since you want to block it what we're
going to do is they're not at the EA and
FTC and everybody else pass it everybody
else say it's a goal we're gonna make
excluded from your region until we can
figure it out over here and then
you can go to your consist constituents
and you can tell them the reason why
they don't have Call of Duty and all the
ABK games over here in this small region
y'all can rock with Sony as much as
y'all want I want to see how many region
changes happen that night
yo we give it to everybody
if you're in the regions that can accept
it if you if listen if everybody in the
brain again oh
man what's going on they hating on us
today man they hate doing this bruh no
we back no I see it back we back okay
everybody from the Bronx Queens Staten
Island Long Island is rocking with us
and Brooklyn don't want to listen don't
give it to Brooklyn
hey Brooklyn don't eat that's exactly
what's gonna happen you know CMA y'all
want to do it like that y'all people
don't get that chance to eat and if you
want to eat over here go go region
change your box put it to the good old
USA UK so the UK can't eat and they're
gonna have to complain you can't eat
right now since y'all want to act up and
you don't want to smile and think
everything is all cool when you block um
if your box don't do this if your box
don't go
you ain't in baby oh man that's I want
Microsoft to do you guys like that I
cannot wait y'all turning them into the
evil empire
they have been nice they have went to
your doors they have talked about it's
like they just like you know Jehovah
Witness nothing bro can I can I uh talk
to you about the book of uh acts
do you have a couple of minutes you
gotta use a different references
you know you know would you like to talk
you know take a couple of time out you
know to talk about the book of eggs
the cloud will have us living in the
paradise but they tried to do that let's
go they have been nice to you and all
you have doing has been slamming the
door spitting in people's faces
reporting them to the police doing all
types of evil things to do
you're going to turn them into the
monsters oh
you are literally
gonna force them to be the evil empire
all right now you're gonna you you're
making the instrument of your own
destruction by doing the evil practices
to the good kid oh
you turn into good kid bad and when that
good kid turns bad they ain't going back
from rotten is going to be literally
whooped butt nation and you guys are
going to watch this is how y'all become
app this I know you're gonna become an
app so bad because let's let's say this
right let's say this thing gets blocked
in his entirety that's about to ask you
how evil
do you believe they become when when
they run out this and correct give me a
single give me a Capcom give me a square
and they start just buying people and
grabbing them up Phil
what you want to become
a dog that Genghis Khan it is oh we be
in conquerors now I've won him I want
you know what it is is because he has
been nice he has been kissing baby
shaking hands and been nice y'all been
saying oh he's two nights Microsoft has
been turned another cheek when y'all
been doing these things I want them to
become the Genghis Khan of this and if
it takes this deal
to force them to look over and say
nobody's playing nice but us tired of
playing nice let's go rip their heads
off because we have a bigger Army why
are the people with the bigger Army
treating you nice with kid gloves while
you keep throwing rocks and spitting in
their face at what point in time are
they gonna look over at you and say you
know what I'm tired of you little Aunt
they kick me down the block
we call it Scorch Earth I want I I
wanted them to eliminate them from the
beginning I wanted them to break them
and throw them away a long time ago I
never forget what happened to Satan and
until it happens to you I'm not gonna
give up I'ma stay on this team so the
fight ain't over oh Brooke your guys are
gonna get this work so if you thought
you was going to Super Chat and shut me
up now they saying you got the glow they
said you got that glove
which when it happens
I want y'all I want y'all to remember
each and every last podcast that it
threw in the towel oh and I want you to
remember who stand next to Phila
Microsoft until a very bitter oh and I
want you to put my name up there with
the pantheons of the truth Fly by Night
Xbox dude oh you stated on it I don't
know it's over you know maybe we can go
look at Sega no we gonna get this deal
done but we gonna go get Sega and we're
gonna go get Capcom and we're gonna put
this work in because you will be an app
within the next 10 years it's over you
will be an app and I'm standing on this
no PlayStation 6. for Glory's sake whoa
I just need you to say King real quick I
just need you to look at the camera and
go who is the baddest who is the battle
down
the mean is low bro
lick my calm tell that chicken hearted
son of yours and to be at the designated
time
don't give up
you you next
you won't fall in line see this is what
I want to see happen
you say now we good with it oh that
would be crazy I want to watch these
dudes turn tail and run for the mountain
because you're coming for me now y'all
think it's all sweet y'all think y'all
go I'mma supposed to back down because
y'all came a hundred strong in my house
first we had the dog getting punched
work
and up till I get to the 90s
yo CMA stop blocking us man this has
been having fun we having fun with this
tablet I gotta stop blocking this stream
man this is a fun IOP look real quick I
had to ask you this
obviously the critical date [__] at EU I
believe it's May 22nd you know what I'm
saying now if the EU
says no okay
you know does Microsoft Fight This on
all three fronts or do at that point you
gotta say you know what
what is it three billy that they all
Activision and the deal don't go through
like what do you say ksrt in that
scenario if the EU is not on board
so so at this point it's not just within
Microsoft's Court we would like it to be
but it's not right uh uh uh Bobby has
been on record at least three times and
they they try to pin him down on are you
guys ready and willing to renegotiate if
if need be and he's kind of slipping and
dodging here he won't say that because
obviously that is a bored decision right
right and that would be basically be
acknowledging that they're going to be
active for another year or two right and
uh you know you don't know that there's
there's a lot of there's a lot of
context in the middle that makes it
difficult to call One Way or Another
like if you look at as soon as this deal
this block came uh what do you call it
the the the stock of of Activision felt
like a stone yeah but the one on
Microsoft went up you know so it's kind
of like people the the money men are
saying to Microsoft we like that this
didn't go through step back kind of the
thing all that in in the soup makes it a
little difficult to call it right uh for
those who argue that they need to stand
on their square and and at least get
some concessions right from these
regulatory bodies because they need to
establish the fact that hey we got the
money we should be allowed to purchase
things if we want to I agree with that
even if it doesn't ultimately lead to
the deal getting passed there needs to
be some fight right because if you oh if
you're able to have your money and you
can't purchase as you want to purchase
that sets a very dangerous precedent
right like that that's like saying you
can only do what the what the market
leader dictates that's just very strange
that's a world we shouldn't we shouldn't
want to live in right you know uh my
Sony brings all their tools to the table
right the reason why something like the
last of us can be as great as it is on
TVs because Sony has that prowess
imagine saying Sony you can do this
battle but you can't use your your your
Hollywood uh uh uh tools right into this
Microsoft ain't got that like that's
ridiculous right you bring the tools you
have to the fight and that's just how
it's done so I do think that they should
at least fight the good fight on that
but they need to learn to walk and chew
gum at the same time right they just
need to do that okay because as they're
doing that you know their console the
console Brethren all the folks around
are like yo you left us behind oh second
class citizens oh this and that you know
and we we ain't going we ain't going we
ain't gonna talk about the FPS you know
yeah situation in the room yeah
I personally think it's Honda Civic
problems
cases
they need to fight the good fight and
make sure that the people they brought
to the dance the the the consumers who
love the brand still feel that that
brand is worthwhile absolutely and it
seems like from from what they've done
they've shown historically they have a
problem doing that you have more money
than almost anybody but somehow you know
you can either work on ABK and forsake
your your your platform or you work on
the platform and if you say you know you
you just say we're good I I totally
understand what you did and hopefully
you know one of the things regardless of
whether it goes through or not is the
refocus on what's on the home front so
to speak right and as far as any one
potential Acquisitions that could have
been stymied or on hold because all
resources were diverted towards ABK and
then also like you said just from an
Xbox game Studio standpoint obviously we
had Patrick on earlier you know we
talked about mismanagement as far as 343
is concerned and there are concerns as
far as that right is concerned as far as
managing what you got but be clear
though I do want to be clear that you
know I do feel that if this does get
blocked it still does not preclude they
still need Studios if your mission if
your ethos is to be game pass at a
subscription service you need steady
content 2022 proved that because
Bethesda wasn't able to deliver a
redfall and Starfield at that time there
was nothing else in the pipe so that's
why you need these Studios because again
game development takes long you know
what I'm saying and and again you need
that quarterly Cadence of official but
as king as king is put eloquently put it
right they're trying to do it on the up
and up method right if if this is
completely blocked you're basically
telling them that the way Sony does it
is the way that it's done right so now
you're going to see money hat Studios
left and right and you're going to see
that because that's the only way forward
at that point because that means they
got to be sneaking acquiring uh
developers at the moment yeah as as we
speak as this is going down it's just
the fact that they're not uh of that
scale
they're not getting Distributors
producers uh people that can run their
own businesses what they're getting is
smaller developers that can fit in and
well again
um they just bought the Bungie extended
Studio basically yeah yeah pretty much
the new fireworks it's basically
extended that's right that's right so
yeah you know it is what it is like
personally I think it's super
interesting right but at the end of the
day I feel like this this needs to go
back to Merit so that way everyone can
be clear whether you like that the deals
passes or fail we can all at least
establish a framework that all right
they they this is this is the barometer
that they used right by by and large
were done the minute they started
talking about high performance consoles
y'all lost like the Nintendo switch
don't care even though they existed
while Nintendo's their Scrooge counting
their money like sure we are not part of
this game it's ridiculous you know so it
is it just needs to be at the Merit
that's where I like it and one thing
this is exposed is the lack of
regulators knowledge of the games
industry and how they had to be educated
on so many things but we'll see what
happens on that front get it on uh
taking the money from somebody and doing
things
yeah listen I'm gonna tell you oh
okay this smells terribly of corruption
and
don't think at some point in time that
that won't come out it will be a book
like later on someplace and all that
stuff will come out and you'll find out
who deep throat is
see that was from uh you know uh this
guy's days back in the days where you
know um for most part what was going on
with the presidency but um
we will find out what went down who went
down because I find it highly suspect
that Miss Khan met with the CMA a couple
of days before and the tune changed you
know so I find it highly suspect that
that happens and don't tell me that you
didn't have conversations about what's
the biggest thing that you're dealing
with at the moment and you can tell me
oh we didn't talk about that well where
was the recordings to there
you know who was the person who was the
independent dude that was sitting there
next to you that was listening they
could say nah yo for sure he didn't talk
about that I don't trust you that it
wasn't talked about um you was
embarrassed on air you know when the
senator got up there and told you why
are you protecting the market leader uh
the CMA was down for whatever you know
at that point and they know if that were
to pass right there if the CMA would
have passed that right then the next was
the EU and that would have fell in the
FTC and that would have went just
straight through
um you're gonna who's at the end of the
day Microsoft is fitting the bill and
then this is to you Microsoft okay
remember who made you pay money and who
dragged you through all this extra
process
don't forget what is political
ramifications that call it go to your
favor if we're going down this route as
far as UK and
you know post brexit and then Microsoft
who helps with their military and yeah
security hacking and yeah this could go
down another route it's a whole
different thing it'll be interesting to
see
if the fight does continue with the
appeal process and stuff like that how
far that goes the only my only concern
is that it then goes back to the CMA if
they get that which
percentage-wise is is is interesting on
success rate but I will say this you
know EU pay attention to what happens
with the EU I'm very curious that's it
right there that's that's going to be
the Curious one yeah right there so we
got that I know um King's gonna be
babbling soon before we do it when we
get these super chats first or well you
know you want me to do it okay I think
you've been
yeah yeah well for the most part for
most of us learning a second language in
high school in college wasn't exactly
the high point of our academic careers
you know I was with computer science
now thanks to Babel the language
learning app that has sold more than 10
million subscriptions there is a fun and
easy way to learn a new language whether
you're traveling abroad connecting in a
deeper way with family or you just have
some free time Babu teaches bite-sized
language lessons that you can actually
use in the real world
you know I'm in New York so everybody
talks extra different languages and I
just want to be part of the conversation
you know in my household you know I pick
Spanish so Spanish is you know the
language that I wanted to learn so you
know that's what it is Babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go bamboo expertly
crafted lessons are built around real
life you learn how to have practical
conversations about travel relationships
business and more other language lesson
apps use AI for their lesson plans but
Babel's lessons was created by a hundred
language experts their teaching methods
have been scientifically proven to be
effective with Babel you can choose 14
different languages including Spanish
French Italian and German
that's so funny I can't wait to learn
German
plus Babel's speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
punctuation and your accent there are so
many ways to learn with Babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts Games videos stories and even
live class lessons plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning Journey today with
Babel
right now get up to 55 off of your
subscription when you go to babel.com
iron Lords that's babel.com iron Lords
for up to 55 off of your subscription
Bible language for life no doubt I'm
glad we babbling you know what I'm
saying because I need to get my Spanish
up so I was glad you educated the realm
it works really well with you know
um where's the bathroom uh how to start
how to get through stuff yeah so I'm
learning like the smaller aspects of it
and I was always embarrassed because you
know my grandmother's you know Puerto
Rican and that side of the family and
I'm with you know my wife and we at the
house and everybody's speaking Spanish
so I got to say como
real slow no me gusto
learning it is is helping me so I
practice with my lessons with her so it
yeah you want to learn a second language
no doubt so look let me apologies in
advance on the super chats y'all because
it's all broken up it's in three
different streams I can only deal with
what I have right now so if anybody says
something that we missed we're gonna try
to make this right with soft next week
hopefully what y'all could do is if you
left a Super Chat and it's not in this
chat y'all can at Cog and it in the chat
and just write it regular and comment
and I'll try to read it that way that's
a good good point so I see the last one
I got honestly is Lucius Augustus
remember for 20 months since his
decision uh multiple companies have
stated concerns and companies are
leaving the UK stock market and
decreasing future investment CMA done
effed up interesting
we got uh Dragonheart Yobe 5 super chat
Phil Spencer is Hulkamania he's tired of
being nice it's time to bring out
Hollywood Spencer and create the NWO for
life I think so I'm with you on that I
really think they have to stop being
nice and just go for the juggler yeah
interesting Jay Rembert five dollar
Super Chat King is Right Microsoft needs
to stop being a nice guy at least when
it comes to Sony anyway then we got
Spartan gold star got skipped okay smart
and ghost 72 two pounds Super Chat Sony
will be selling cartridges when the
death settles okay okay that's what he
got you know what I'm saying no that's
again if I know I've missed a ton of
super chats but brother so I was not
here at attic is not here so again if I
missed it
um please
um again you can add me directly I'll
try to read that during the show and get
that popping and then we want to move on
to our final topic which I'm glad
caseanti is sticking around for because
I'm very very curious on his thoughts Oh
shot we have a five pound super chat
from the sagging nut sack I I don't
understand the sudden goal post move
from Call of Duty to now cloud gaming
what change is Google snitching too
no I don't I don't think so I think that
uh they have very good lawyers as well
and I got to give some of his flowers
yes Saul said this from the beginning
what he said that Call of Duty stuff is
not the thing y'all supposed to be
looking at Cloud he did say that and I I
think we're gonna have to wrap Sovereign
up and put him in a closet until this is
over everything that he's been saying is
like they're taking notes from what he
is saying and they're using his joints
his his words as a cheat sheet because
if he was ever going to attack this deal
the only place that you can attack this
deal from is this space is uh cloud
gaming because Microsoft has the largest
infrastructure when it comes to that and
somebody said well Sony has VR and
they're not going at Sony you know uh
for having a controllable uh space and
console with VR listen to me
that's apples and oranges right uh Sony
does have a cloud type of system right
Microsoft isn't in the VR space with
Sony at all right so when that happens
then they can have that conversation but
Sony is in this space and the fact that
they're telling them oh well we can't
grow in a space because of this and oh
uh look at Google Google died because of
this and his record stating it used to
failure of course right because of that
this is the reason why a stadia couldn't
grow they're looking at this and saying
that if Microsoft does get Call of Duty
and all these other games and are able
to roll out games in a secession type of
um way it would be detrimental for
anybody trying to grow in this space and
and technically technically if you look
at it uh two things first the CMA is
using get all of game passes numbers
yeah as using that as uh clouds their
Cloud infrastructure like we don't have
the breakdowns but there's no way most
people who who use Game Pass also play
Cloud I play Cloud right and I'm a rare
Beast I I have a g Cloud over here I
enjoy it but most people don't like it
right so if you look at the whole 29 30
million of subscriber base and say
that's your Cloud that that's first and
foremost a very very skewed number
secondly if you're talking about the
size of the infrastructure technically
the biggest cloud infrastructure is AWS
yes just because not a lot of people are
there does not mean that their footprint
isn't still dwarfing Microsoft so in
both cases it's kind of it's kind of
weak sauce you know it's kind of you
know good point especially on the uh The
Game Pass subscriber breakdown as that
doesn't represent the entire of them
actually accessing that we would love to
know the breakdown of those who actually
use the cloud it's probably not as big
as we think good point good point so
look when you get into this topic this
is my topic as far as the Asus Rock I'm
calling it rocket sounds a [__] but
shout out to Rog Republican Gamers you
know obviously uh IOP and launch
gaming.net were privilege to go to the
reveal event and um yeah I just want to
talk about it really quick um appreciate
the love from all the major Outlets as
far as um uh kind of sourcing our
coverage shout out to Tom Warren shout
out to the fox who are what you call it
had on uh ksrt had on the gaming Circle
podcast and also gave some love to to
myself and then launchgaming.net but
yeah it's been revealed man so um we got
that ryzen Z1 and that rdna3 FSR 100
1080p 120 hertz free screen uh freesync
with a seven inch display 500 next you
know we're talking about our
full-fledged Windows 11 gaming on this
device ice Wi-Fi six you know um again
as far as the SSD upgrade ability
internally and then you can also use a
Micro SD and then you know very
lightweight very lightweight devices one
of the things I noticed off the back
when I picked up the device as a steam
deck owner my man this is really light
and then the the picture quality was
outstanding grips were at an angle d-pad
people had some questions because I
guess it is circle d-pad truth I got it
before I make a definitive whether or
not it's a goal I did fire up Street
Fighter 5 that they had on it because
all right let me put it through the oil
you can and the fireball test usually
those are good and I was able to get
them joints out so again we need more
data to more more reference points but
my initial fear was man this really
feels good it felt like a premium device
we'll say off the bat very quiet very
quiet as far as fan noise I have two
fans inside yeah dual fan dual speakers
in the front uh Adobe Atmos and again
you know for me not saying that no
devices ever done this but for me one of
the major attractions for me as a steam
deck owner the games I want to play I
can't unless I go through extra steps
which is again I'm a destiny player you
know Destiny is banned because of you
know the Linux situation on that you
know again you know I PL I want to I
don't want to play streaming all the
time because of my travel I'm on a plane
I'm on the accelerate Amtrak with Lords
we go in the packs you know say I'm in
situations where I'm not going to be
able to stream and access to Cloud so
having native game pass downloadable to
device is critical to me right so having
been able to log into my Xbox PC game
pass account have all my achievements
continue my game that kind of stuff is
really appealing and the fact that I
gotta be honest y'all Microsoft being in
the building with AMD with Asus and Asus
really showing their commitment to being
a gaming platform as well as Microsoft
say hey fully fledged Windows 11 we are
really spearheading driver support and
making sure you have the latest firmware
stuff for the games that's critical to
me so and the number the other thing
that was really huge is the fact that
their Champion a multi-store front
device okay you don't like Game Pass hey
we epic game store you can put on this
hey you're a steam guy hey we can still
put the Steam on my you know app on it
and and you can still rock your steaming
and I tested steam I play ghost ghost
runner on Steam playing phenomenal you
know have been able to have your stuff
there you know and um Ubisoft I believe
their store Front was there as well so
look it's ambitious you know my only key
was okay
what's this price going to be because
you know you're talking all this
performance and what did I tell you
before it it even happened well the
rumors you know it leaks I can't count
with whatever I'll let you out there are
leaks that are that are coming out right
now as far as what what it could be and
um you know if they're able to hit that
Target it does seem like a Steve deck
competitor from a price point standpoint
so I want to start with with K because
you know I know you don't lost them deck
Lord G Cloud you know I don't know if
he's the biggest fan of the Ally you
ever bored giving me feelings that you
use a hater
yeah he's about to smoke so you know you
know what are your thoughts on the on
the first the the the wrong Ally the the
the the hype about the device and then
also your thoughts were the rumors of a
potential price point overall so wait
where you at with this
so okay so let me get into this by by
just establishing the groundwork here
all right let me just establish you can
set the Rules of Engagement yeah yes
because because I I have been
misconstrued I haven't bought out here
saying things go ahead he's out here
frauding on my name
let's go
let's go no no okay so so
um I am super excited about the rogi I
just am why because because this this
environment this this platform has been
around for a long time yeah way before
steam jumped in right and and it took
someone like valve to jump in with their
their with their business model in order
to make it attractive for others to
follow suit right you see AMD following
suit with with releasing reference chips
that then others can then can then
piggyback off of right so so that is
exciting to me okay like all your points
that you were making uh lower Cognito uh
I agree with because I am I myself am am
a member who who has an SD card that
runs Windows 11 right because I want to
be able to play that Windows stuff in
addition to my Steam games and all that
right so I completely understand and of
course as soon as that starts talking
about this I know slow mo is going to be
in the chat like the Velvet the valve
marketing exactly okay remember our
contract oh man you can't slow but we
did I see you right there no so so I I
there are there are certain problems on
the window side that I'm hoping the the
rogi will resolve right uh Universal
controller support because steam steam
doesn't have that so you have to install
a third-party application that will give
you that right they are very they have
like when I first bought the steam deck
I was very much oh tomorrow I'm
installing Windows right yeah and over
time when you're using it I'm sure you
know this right when you're using it you
you appreciate the Steam OS and how it's
integrated with the hardware right so I
am so excited for this Market to to be
to be established and have a lot more
players in it you know salute to the
ioneals of the world who've been doing
like great work for a long time but
they've been at like laptop prices so
most people don't pay attention to that
to that market right uh to the GPD wins
who've also been doing amazing work and
even actually I think the GPD win as
soon as this news of the rock Ally came
out GPD win showed off their prototype
which has exactly the wrong Ally specs
but in a smaller footprint I'm just like
how they doing this amazing right but
the reason now I say all that to say I'm
excited for it let that let the let the
record show
hey where I bring that not hate when I
bring caution is the reason why I am
excited the reason why I have been
excited for the steam deck is because
they got me with the hardware right and
and I'm all over the place I built a
very powerful rig and I also have a
teeny tiny system that I use in my hands
and depending on what game I'm playing I
play between the two actually these days
uh uh midnight Sons lives on the steam
to me it is what it is right so so I I
have no dog in the fight I have all the
consoles so I get to play wherever I
want I appreciate that it is what it is
man baby right here salute
right but what got me what has now
established me as a deck fan is not the
hardware but the support of valve since
that Hardware has been released right
salute to salute to facebook slash meta
who showed the way where when you start
Hardware a certain place you offer a
certain price and then you you
exponentially make that Hardware better
over time yes so later when they say oh
by the way this thing is now a hundred
dollars more as much as it may hurt you
you look at the rap sheet of what it can
do now and go yo when I first bought
this thing you could do a quarter of the
things it can do now yes so maybe it
justifies it that is my whole focus with
steam with with the steam deck versus
the the support respect now let me be
clear in why I say that I have a big
long history with Asus I make a lot I
build a lot of machines I build my
latest machine my motherboard build a
lot of PCS right like when I build my
PCS the thing that ends up of course is
here
so so
with Asus specifically yes they are a
company that they they're kind of like a
one and done type of type of situation
right where where do they get the money
when you buy the hardware that's when
they get the money right they have no
reason to keep you anymore until the
next piece of Hardware that you will buy
from gotcha unlike your PlayStation
right unlike your Xbox with the software
because that's right it's a loss leader
they know that they know that they're
gonna keep this machine as pristine as
they can they're going to keep iterating
on it because you will then buy from
their app store and then you'll continue
to move the ball forward right same
thing as in the the Facebook metal quest
Quest 2. they started they iterated upon
iterated upon iterating to make sure
that that Hardware continues to shine
and you want a place to buy their
software right
Asus does not have said history right
right they don't have an app store they
don't have any way for you to to double
dip and and and and get more money out
of you so their first their first
situation is you bought the hardware
we're done we move along right and
because of that I got to look at it with
a little bit of a side up right because
that's their business model right right
because you you do all the great
Hardware at me right uh the the specs
and the speeds and feeds I'm the speeds
and feeds guy I love all that I know
that yeah right so you threw all of it
at me some of them some of it is a bit
more dubious than others yeah 120 hertz
screen yeah we're hitting 120 hertz yeah
we don't stop yeah yeah that's gonna be
over the game unless you're playing like
Nintendo like yeah you're playing like
freaking Super Mario Brothers three
you're not hitting 120 you gotta love
that they got that it's cool that's cool
it's absolutely but I feel you on a
practical day-to-day usage some of it is
snake oil but by and large the specs are
great right my problem is like quick
example Elden ring came out right y'all
remember Elder ring the greatest game
ever right when it first came out at for
about two weeks there were a lot of
hitching issues yeah across the board
right do you know where it played best
steam deck why because valve saw there
was an issue and they modified proton to
smooth out the frame pacing respect I
don't expect that that Aces will be
focused on that monitoring it for that
let me push back a little let me let me
put this back let me get my Asus rap to
talk to you okay so my Asus rep said
yeah but I guess I you make it extremely
valid points brother like I'm not gonna
say you're not and I guess for me from a
practical standpoint one of my biggest
frustration as much as you said with the
elderman was the the fact that so many
games I love were not steam deck
verified right so the thing that really
impressed me in one of the uh videos
when we had the Microsoft gaming we want
to see a VP is a gaming up there was
that
it seemed that micros the vibe I got
from Microsoft was like look we ain't
really gonna make no Hardware ourselves
right so we're gonna sit there and look
and pick who we feel is ideal for what
we would try to do if we were in this
space and the thing that surprised me
was the game support there now to your
point you're correct Aces doesn't make
any software they don't they don't you
know I mean like they they but it's
Windows right so that's a different
world right and they kept stressing the
windows in the windows 11 aspect and I'm
just curious to your point because you
you are you have valid concerns that if
they would be more committed this
Republic of getting more committed with
the windows 11 and the Microsoft support
and if Microsoft truly does back them as
their quote-unquote XBox handheld that's
what I want to see man yeah you you
should show me a uh approved by by Xbox
made for you know more than just oh you
could play game pass on this right like
show me that you have a first party
whether it be Microsoft or PlayStation
or it doesn't matter show me you have a
first party even steam like show me
valve is backing it because like in my
world I want valve to buy like like Aya
Neo and make that their Hardware
division because I Neo makes amazing
devices right show me you have the
backing of one of these first party
store owners that tells me that you now
have incentive because they might be
slipping you some some dope right you
have an incentive to keep that thing
shining right you show me that and I'm
I'm there right like if you leave it to
their devices kind of like how the G
cloud has been left to the devices
it doesn't like some of us know what
we're doing with that thing you know
like I'm I'm I'm I'm at a dentist or
something I got I got you know
the greatest games ever played on on
this device without connecting and
that's neither here nor there um
yes right under normal circumstances if
you leave this device alone because
honestly before I before I got into the
whole deck situation it was the hardware
that got me there but I will tell you
it's their support uh yes absolutely to
Nvidia Believe It or Not Nvidia the
Nvidia Shield that has been out since
the year before the switch came out and
I still have my Nvidia Shield here and
every two three months I get a new
update that gives it more features
that's important that has become
surprisingly valuable right because as
games change as nuances pop up they're
there to adaptations
switch yes
of
I love my shield I still use it on a
daily right I still use it to this very
day because Nvidia see what you will in
the GPU space they might be clowning but
but on the shield they have kept that
thing shining for sure years right and
that's what that's what I value the fact
that hey I buy this thing moving forward
they got me the support now let me be
clear 100 there are there are places in
Windows that that Asus has a leg up the
the universal controller I'm talking yes
if they have a universal control scheme
that you just pop it up in every control
every single App Store sees it I love it
that's big that would be huge that's big
um oh excuse me I see they're using the
the the Armory crate which is their
their interface which I use that for my
motherboards and stuff they have a
modified version if it allows for
integration between different app stores
yes yes I can confirm we need to confirm
because
yes the thing that impressed me was
again it was like four buttons the first
two would be the equivalent of the start
and select icons that the Xbox
controller would use right then they
obviously had the short key shortcut key
mappings in the back then the bottom two
buttons on the bottom right was the
Armory crate when I pulled up Armory
crate it listed all the games on the
device regardless of storefront so it
had ghost Runner steam icon here comes
my Hi-Fi Rush Xbox icon like it had
everything very streamlined and
organized the other button I believe was
kind of like the performance and
statistic nerd stuff which is yeah all
that good stuff so that part I was like
okay this is pretty intuitive in terms
of that but I hear what you're saying in
reference to you know having that type
of UI that is is integrated and it's not
even accessible in that way the ultimate
goal that I have right and this is me
being real like I want the Rog I like
succeed myself an ever born Saga have a
bet he says I'll be there day one I said
not so much sir because the PC I built
right now took me four years to even
have a hole so I'm not buying a big one
let me buy one soon right but my
ultimate goal is we all saw the the
hackathon or whatever where Microsoft
had the UI I want I'm from the old
school you know team Gray beard back in
the day Microsoft used to have a media
center interface you used to buy Windows
you put the MCE the media center I had
my I had my PC in the living room load
up and every PC integrated with it some
way it had a front end for consuming
entertainment I want a front end that
you can go to the App Store download and
whether you have a GPD win whether you
have a steam deck whether you have a rug
Ally whatever it is you load up the
front end it integrates right and you
have yourself a console like UI right
good point if that is what happens here
because there's more investment and more
excitement in that space
um like you were saying uh [__] they're
loading Windows on this I need them to
be more judicious in how they use
Windows because Windows 11 from jump is
bloated Hardware it's bloated software
it really is right I'm loading tiny 11
online which is literally Windows 11 but
stripped off and all you do is you
download the ones you need right there
are ways for them to succeed and if if
when it comes out and I'm waiting for
the Lords of gaming.net full review and
it looks like they got it all straight
yeah
you you you impressed with the device
you just want to see a couple more
things to really get you over the hump
and before I give it to King the last
part I want to say that I thought was
really because again if we didn't really
touch on the price rumors but if the
rumors are to be true then to me that
shows that not only they're aggressive
are trying to compete in the space
esteem deck but also let's be honest all
these other devices that have tried to
accomplish this they can't compete
because they can't get chips in the at
the volume at that price so what that
shows me is asus's commitment when the
bulk amount that must have been
purchased to get it to this price point
to get this expressed by like right that
is big it being at Best Buy alone yeah
you can just walk into a store and just
pick it up pick it that is monstrous
monstrous that is huge
yeah it showed me the commitment so
we'll see but I'm curious about King you
know what I'm saying where he at he's
been he's been kind of on the money with
these leaks in these rumors on price
point and what's his uh
um
hey Tom please
um I did say this would be 6.99 and uh
apparently there's a nice little leak
that
has changed
right 100
listen bruh
I get emails and DMS too your NDA dude
now no no actually
I laugh and I just wait for it to come
out but you know I give my prediction
ahead of time yes can I just say you
know it's based off of me hey I do have
a cheat sheet as well
um so 6.99 sounds about fine but what
they're introducing all right so
full transparency
Cog and I
was to was supposed to go to this event
from Asus and um
you know the wrong Ally was was that
this is this is the machine that I'm
looking for yeah right I was Boy
before they even said that we were able
to go to this thing I was I can't wait
to see this thing this thing looks crazy
and because you know the gcloud
um I was into that until I found out
exactly what it was right and it's
pretty much what the PlayStation is
going to be trying to do
um so that's why that price point sticks
I don't believe that PlayStation will
lower their price point would be 290
Kyle Henderson what's your needs by the
way the time I I want this console so
send it to me when it come out he got to
come on the show and talk to you yeah
you'll be here
I'm doing a live unboxing I would like
overnight
um I already shipping so I can priorly
open it up
um
so I wasn't able to go
we had to sign the ndas right right and
um being that I wasn't able to go I'm
not beholding to the ND
come on
the machine
from the resolution of the screen
uh looked incredible to the positions of
the con the button lays out layout the
fact that it's using Windows 11. so you
know Cog went in with a specific set of
questions that he was asking and then he
also found out other stuff while you're
there that you can you know adapt on the
fly so I got to give a true respect to
my my brother for going to this event
Alone
um and capturing everything that we
asked for in the background
uh and was able to adapt on the fly to
ask uh in-depth questions on the fly in
this environment that was moving fast if
it looks like it was moving slow if
you're on the other end of the camera
it's moving really fast and he has to
have the adaptability to get all the
information that you guys that aren't
there are able you know to get so loads
of gaming.net had all that information
up in those videos is up right now so if
you can see in depth uh boots on the
ground journalism thank you you know not
somebody that's waiting for information
to come to him and regurgitating it
somebody that's actually going out
getting the information and formatting
it and bringing it back to you and
bite-sized chunks you know like Cog is
the Battle of this right he's he's gonna
allow you to uh interpret this and he's
going to help you through it so I want
to say thank you for being there and
being one of the first people to bring
that out on something that I really
wanted now
I know Microsoft
was always going to
funnel out
um the making of a console all you guys
always I want Microsoft to make a
console I want Microsoft to make a
console on Microsoft did a cloud console
uh uh with a gcloud
they participated with that if you want
Game Pass it's on there that logo was on
the box with them you know and they're
like yo check this out and videos
working on that and then they went with
a direct competitor hey Sue Smith with
that and you're going to get the ryzen
AMD chipset in there and Microsoft was
with them from the ground up that game
pass is and stuff is downloadable onto
the device that's what makes it more
appealing to me and it's running Windows
11. so if you look at the interview
Microsoft was with them hand in hand
Step It Away making sure that things
were working from a software standpoint
and I think this is where Microsoft puts
their foot in the console space without
being
tied to manufacture and do all this
other stuff right they just giving you
the software what they're good at
they're great at Hardware but why uh
Splinter up your group in your sections
when you can have somebody that is great
as Hardware their self right in that
space and they're deficient at software
I think this becomes the official
handheld of Microsoft going forward I I
think it battles a steam deck on all
fronts I I think they have a good chance
to carve out a small niche in this
handheld space for premium owners
because 700 is not nothing you know to
just you know wipe your nose out this is
something serious this is a serious
piece of tech and if it can deliver the
two times uh hardware specs that they're
talking about up uh above the steam deck
then they might have something truly
special what I do like about it is you
can use it like a switch on the go yeah
or docking and Cog did ask them
uh what's the battery life
so it does a little bit and dodging a
little bit the guy dodged a lot not a
little bit he did a whole Matrix move
and he was like depending on the
software that is being used this thing
will give you a varied amount
in The Matrix videos
some in the position to know say that
it's exactly the same battery capacity
as the steam deck yeah which gives me
also a little pause because you're
giving me more watts yeah yeah but not
more battery yeah makes me go hmm
whole hour and a half on on Tekken
you have a smooth 45 minutes on Street
Fighter six but uh but you plug you you
have the ability to dock it true that
that's where they won for me it looks
like a switch more robust and more
powerful to run those games and it's
running Windows 11. I'm in on this thing
oh
biggest thing just more than anything
let's go that's the lights yeah I go for
it I didn't think I would care about
that stuff there's two things that
surprise me about the device one I was
like damn at first I was like they made
it white but then when I put it in my
hand I'm like yo this thing looks sleek
bro like I didn't know y'all were RGB
dudes
I'm not really a person like that the
first thing I was like can you turn that
off that's just because you don't be I'm
thinking battery life he's like yeah you
can turn up but I'm knock on front kick
it's something about it's very sexy
looking you see it is
with your hoodie on and it's a dog and
then people
this is specifically for King because we
know that we know that you know
maybe maybe Lord Cog has oh I'm
compromised
okay so so that's 700 that is let's go
for the Z extreme chipset right that's
the higher end yeah so that's what the
rumor has been the rumor speculation
yeah seven 700 for the higher end which
is 51 more than the steam deck variant
of the high end right right so what's
the low end cost because they have the
they have the Z and the Z extreme
they've only they've only rumored the Z
extreme which is 700.
there's been rumors on both parts okay
so I don't know what the what the reward
I can't comment but if you look at Wario
64. yeah I would say that the lowest end
will probably be uh 550 600. okay you
know I think they're gonna keep playing
in that space yeah
guys like us don't do anything less than
the best
so I didn't I never looked at what was
the only way because I mean let me tell
you like steam deck had I known I would
have brought the middle middle of the
one because the high-end one that I did
buy most of it I could have changed out
myself anyway right right but you don't
know it like like you say King we see
these the plethora of choices and I'll
give you the best one yeah but it's
always the it's always best to get to
the best part and been like oh I could
have changed this I I could have did
that but it was done for me
like you know like you peasants you
imagine change your SSD and go inside
the back of your console and rip your
wings off and sliding on a different SSD
I'll just put that [__] at the back of
my box I I don't do I don't do manual
labor
premium time I've never dreamed of a job
and I don't I don't buy consoles or
anything to to work
I see that SpongeBob SquarePants meme
yeah yeah very very picky the air energy
right now this man says going for the
highest and he doesn't concern about
that
what the little man is doing
yeah excuse me TCL owner
pardon me
you're in my way
I'm going to the premium oh you would
know about that life
yo that's with everything we do we go
inside someplace and it's the best
feeling in the world to be like they go
when we was at the hotel you had the
broke side of the hotel I can't with him
and then you had this side of the hotel
where we was at when when the CEO was
like oh which side of the hotel are you
on well on that side of the hotel he
looked at you with the oh you like the
premium Vlog he did they did it was
different you definitely did because if
we would have said we were sort of broke
side he would be like excuse me
I cannot live okay okay real quick uh
check your DM when you get a chance I
just said yourself to your Twitter your
Twitter DM when you get a chance okay
you can check that out yeah immediately
that'll be quick but uh yeah I mean look
I'll jump in real quick um like I said
you know it definitely feels like the
device for me you know it's a case point
there are still questions We're not
gonna say there's not we still got to
see the benchmarks we still gotta see
performance battery life all that good
stuff but from a standpoint of a you
know Windows dude so to speak you know
what I mean with the option to play
multiple saw fronts and especially Game
Pass is going to be huge for me and I
like I said okay said I really hope
Microsoft Gets behind it really
aggressively and you know I think the
cool thing they got going for them is
the hype train I'm starting to see
people not just you know whether it be
other coverage or my coverage say look
like I I was curious about the device
but now I'm in and it's going to be
interesting to see if that translates so
I believe they have the the launch event
is uh May 11th and that's when they
officially will announce what what said
price is and um yeah I'm curious and for
me I'm definitely gonna pull a king and
go extra premium I'm gonna need docs I'm
gonna need whatever I go for I'm gonna
ice my say I did the same thing with the
steam deck I I used my steam deck out
like high-end the whatever the extreme
model listen put it this way before the
rumors of this really attractive price
point that we heard about I was willing
to spend a Jeep I was like I was like
this didn't sound like it's going to be
G let me put a g aside because I'm in I
need this on the go when I'm going to my
packs
like like not not to not to cut your
butt let's go if you're if you're
willing to spend the G there are like
many really great like other devices
that do exactly this they're actually
give you more for your G no question I
guess my question is what has what has
the and this is a genuine question for
all the people that are excited back
when I was like yo the steam deck is
great people are like I don't care about
about handhelds yeah the wrong Ally has
seemed to capture some Zeitgeist yeah
that seems to be different so I'm
genuinely concerned like questioning
what what is it that it does I think I
think what it is for me besides the
native game pass which is yeah I knew
that was little native game pass you
besides that which other devices I get
it
it feels first of all it's a sexy
looking device and it feels like
Microsoft is going
so for me that part is right man I hope
so when I see when I see the execs of
Microsoft at this launch event so to
speak I see them speaking what is it the
um uh senior VP uh vice president of
Microsoft gaming devices ecosystem is
there you know um amd's
um architect of you know gaming
Solutions and stuff like that and gaming
marketing from amds when I see these
Heavy Hitters in the room about a device
that you're not making right so to know
I'm sure it shows a level of endorsement
and commitment they offered you know
granted it's you know Game Pass for free
they're talking about yeah we launched
you know Minecraft 11. Minecraft Legend
supposedly around a thing to me it feels
like Microsoft is kind of hitching their
horse to it so me that I'm never gonna
get an Xbox handheld so to speak this
feels like the spiritual success this
feels like what it should be so and it's
that combination and it just hits a lot
of the check boxes for me as far as the
other things you know what I'm saying as
far as the you know the upgradable
stores and all this stuff and again no
disrespect to these other devices it
just feels like the the wrong
has all the figs that an Xbox fan would
look for from a handful that's not Xbox
yeah
it just it's they've been able to get
their marketing oh they're marketing
it's closer
and look you know we'll see you know the
shoot will be seen on support and um
yeah you know as a Game Pass Champion as
a person who wants to play my stuff
consistently you know it just feels like
it is for me but I'm with you I'm with
you because I like everything you're
describing now I do on my deck but I had
to do the manual way you had to install
this I had to install that I had to put
the play night front end on it so that
it's able to like see what you're doing
now you can see I'm a tweaker I'm a
tweaker yes
that's the thing okay the Xbox console
guy doesn't want to tweak anything he
wants to fire it up no it's working you
know it's good to go and as much as you
can eventually get maybe to that same
result there's something that the
console got is always about ease of use
and action exactly convenience
convenience and that's why the Ally I'm
like oh cool I got look cause I'm gonna
be real I'm gonna be real I gotta I
gotta call out y'all like this yeah you
can do you know streaming and against
all right they don't have the native
streaming game and then I read the steps
and I sat there and I'm like this is not
that this is a programming course
anything but this is a lot of steps just
to get something that is truly not
natively supported and the other thing
I'm disappointed in I thought by now how
long were you into the to the to the um
what you call it the steam deck life
cycle now how about a year I think it
just had its it's had its year
anniversary like a few months a few
weeks ago I was just hoping to Microsoft
would be a little bit more aggressive
with working with them and getting this
thing over and getting ready how you can
be absolutely working with them when
you're working with these dudes
when I seen them working with that dude
to me that signifies that you doing half
and half Support over there with steam
yeah you know what I'm saying and you're
really over here think about it when
they first spoke about it they did say
oh well here's the the browser steps for
now while we work on a better client yes
right and that better client never never
up to the point where now there's
actually for those on the deck there's
an app called Green Light which is the
app that Microsoft should have release
release yeah you install and then it
lets you you know so I completely feel
you that's it I will I will have one
request yes please please I see a five
dollar Super Chat oh let's go
I I request that that's not red because
we're gonna go right to that because uh
shout out to the other half of the
gaming Circle podcast you really need to
listen to ever born Saga here five
dollars Super Chat my second brother
don't let que Asanti Gaslight yo he'd be
waiting outside Best Buy overnight in
the rain with no umbrella for the rock
out
for the record sir I wait outside for
nothing sir just show up at my door if I
still choose it that's previous did you
just see the pinky in the air this is
what I'm talking about these guys try to
act like they ain't about that just
because they try to talk that humble
stuff you know you know you know no hey
man look look with with great power
comes great responsibility not
everybody's gonna be out there buying
the ridiculous machines left and right
so I have to I have to speak to the
normal man
you do is you sit there and be like yeah
I'm with you and then until you get up
to that part in the line where you'd be
like all right
[Applause]
get off the line okay see you guys later
I'm going to have lobsters
[Laughter]
so look that's all I got on the Rog Ally
again appreciate big time all the love
and support I have never done a tech
preview ever I've never done any stuff
so a lot of this is a learning
experience and I know like I said they
have my brothers with me obviously
extenuating circumstance because I know
King was gonna be there I felt so bad I
know that's the only time I cried yeah
literally in the car when you know
something like you I had to you that's
that's that's been there near this
finest I left super early I was like
yeah this is gonna get done and I was
really busy I was holding on until to
Hope I was trying to figure out some
stupid way how I can make it happen and
when I realized damn I'm not gonna be
there a tear came down my eye because
I'm like I think this is the one like we
felt that we felt like getting coverage
on this might do something for us and
and it did it was not even that like as
a fan as a fan of gaming and Tech like
we like yo we got an eye on this device
and yeah it was cool to see man and
again just being in the room and you
know Gadget one thing you did one thing
you did that I have to give you credit
for which I don't know if you did that
on purpose or what but continue to do
that every time open multiple things on
any device
multiple things to see how far it went
because a lot of people we were talking
about it even on my show folks were
commenting on on your great video and
they were like yo it had multiple things
open in the background and still the
game that was that was on the main
screen was playing and playing well all
that stuff goes very far I appreciate it
it really does help like it really shows
you know how capable how capable this
device is and really did a great job at
that thank you salute to you and yours
it was it was great I hope you see more
Tech content oh yeah I'm trying I'm
trying man for sure for sure you know
it's definitely something that is of
interest to me is always going to be the
tech I.T geeking me that loves new
technology and you know I think it was
the perfect combination the fact that I
have handheld roots and you know it's
always cool this I was a dude that had
the Atari Links I was the dude that had
you know say anything new that's trying
to be Innovative in that space is really
cool and it was it just felt like a good
combination so thanks for everyone for
showing the love you know what I'm
saying and going out and support and uh
yeah we'll see what happens on the 11th
and all that good stuff I want to get
these uh super chats see anything I miss
and then we'll uh rock out before K uh
what you call it um
[Music]
I think we got him out of there let's be
honest cloud gaming is nowhere near
perfect we need someone like Microsoft
to step up and make it better without
them I don't see cloud gaming going
anywhere I just want to make sure I got
it yeah so that was new Mario 187.
hey y'all
catching bodies with it you know what
I'm saying do you think Xbox should make
the series s at all oh this is the case
question do you think the Xbox should
make the series s into a PC game gaming
handheld device like the steam deck it
will probably change their narrative
into a positive perspective now uh
Casada you've had uh the fox and other
people were talking about this stuff on
your channel your amazing Channel
yeah the fox and if you don't know the
fox says I don't know you should be
following him he he is The Wizard of
engineering yes he he knows what he's
talking about and he'll use the math to
to explain exactly what he's talking
about and he is always right basically
he came on the show and was he called he
called it the the series asked the
Trojan Horse of the of the the console
Market where they are artificially
pegging the series ass they're they're
they're they're limiting its
capabilities even though you plug the
thing into the wall and presumably you
could throw a lot more wattage at it but
they're artificially limiting it like to
uh to an alarming degree to the point
where the question becomes why are they
doing that and if you look at and I'll
leave him to explain a much better check
check his channel out check out our show
but if you if you look at if you look at
the speeds and feeds as as to what he's
describing it's because he's
anticipating that in the Next Generation
when the quality of the socs the system
on chips are better you as a developer
have already created your mobile
handheld game because they limited you
the last gen which is now so they're
kind of secretly making developers build
the next switch Pro kind of game just by
building it the way they are today which
is you know 4D chest stuff that I think
is very interesting I I don't know I
don't know if that's that's really how
they're looking at it maybe it's a very
genius some genius engineers in the
background saying look man you know in
the next Generation the way we're
looking at it it might be interesting
for us to start this now so the
transition is much easier than I'm
looking forward to it I know ever born
saga's out there talking about the
hybrid console future and whatnot this
looks like it's kind of heading in that
direction so it'll be interesting to see
how I'm looking forward to it I don't
know about it becoming a handheld PC
because they will in my estimation
they'll always want to establish that
Xbox ground they'll want to keep it you
know the console I bet you'll see one
that has the same you know the the the
the uh Express chip right right yeah
that will just come out of your console
and plug right into the handheld and you
can keep it moving that way I can
foresee that but yeah I don't know about
it being Windows specifically because
they seem to be separating their grounds
you know this is our Windows audience
yeah
so we we shall see but yeah it's an
interesting time I I am there for it
right the the more the more capable the
small mobile tips become the better of a
chance we have for being able to
establish all these grounds right we you
see last gen consoles where people like
it's the big console it has it has the T
flops that are way less than your phone
at this point right so the time is the
time is near and it's very exciting that
people are jumping into it I just hope
Microsoft is you know Facebook yeah get
in there
this generation and I'm not saying don't
even do the hardware like you're saying
can do not do that Hardware there's so
many partners that are ready to do the
hardware for you yeah just get that just
get that software style yes all right
get that nice front end anybody that
wants to bring their device comes comes
to it the software company and they want
to get back to their Roots they they
don't want to be in this Hardware stuff
and they're going to get to the point
where the infrastructure she's big
enough just have the app and you know
you can play it wherever and they can
partner and the UI and kind of get
accustomed to what KK is talking about
because I do agree with him like if they
have that clean in the face that kit UI
that goes but it could go a long way for
them that that we'll see how you have
your GPD win it comes out you have your
eye anneal they come out they all have
various different levels of Hardware but
they all use Windows if you Microsoft
bring a front end that automatically
adds Your Game Pass right there and
other
win like they're making the hardware for
you it's it's beautiful it's a thing you
know what I mean yeah no definitely and
I I mean for the windows 11 Step I want
to give them credit there I did like the
fact that I could that I was able to
pull up game bar and have the
traditional stuff that I would have on
PC it felt good in that respect so we'll
see what happens I want to get the final
super chats
um the man who got them horns remember
for 29 months Lord Braun show us some
love before the end of the show thank
y'all for rocking with us I know
YouTubers killing us today snipers ever
born Saga five dollar Super Chat the
beauty of Cox coverage is most previews
try to fetishize the tech which really
only serves as an advertisement this was
real world use oh thank you brother yeah
I wanted to put it through his pages I
wanted to come from uh because everyone
there to be honest I didn't feel with
necessarily hardcore Gamers and I want
like I want to give that person what is
a hardcore game I'm going to feel how he
going thing he's going to put it through
the paces and that kind of thing so I
thought that was really cool thank you
for that brother much love voilock Rebel
for 16 months Sony fired uh I think he
said fire oh fired a bunch of Bungee
devs then we rehired them so they make a
new studio to keep the game on Xbox and
PC no ps6 he's riding with you kick he
says
I believe so too no doubt and he said
Slow Mo five dollar Super Chat this was
nice some gaming Circle podcast Vibes
without the constant bad takes and tin
foil hat conspiracy theories what are
you implying sir he's going at effort
what do you have applied at my favorite
Circle what you doing there was no
implication necessary he's speaking
truth right there oh you replying
because one member of the gaming Circle
podcast is not here that there are no
tin falling ever born get your meds get
your men I hold the tin foil hat for him
as the originator of the tinfoil had uh
yeah you were ever born are in pocket
for sure yeah definitely together a lot
of options
salute salute so let's get him out of
here get the pole that we got racket
alright with the CMA recently blocking
Microsoft's acquisition of ABK in the UK
what do you think Microsoft's Next Step
should be moving forward choices are a
appeal based on cloud nascent market and
focus on the EU next
B move on from the deal focus on smaller
Studio Acquisitions for Game Pass C
focus on third-party exclusives and
increasing first party quality or D I
don't care no Call of Duty for you hey
and that's fine let's go anyway that is
the question those are the choices
please Rock the vote when it goes up on
Twitter again I want to salute the
legendary Patrick Ren from respawn which
we had one earlier in segment one of
three four streams YouTube so hopefully
you don't kill us in the algorithm today
but it is what it is we've been sniped
but yo go check that out really talk
about everything what's going on he
addressed the performance issues he
didn't run from it he didn't run from
the Halo infinite situation it's a
former 343 developer he got it please
check that out go support it I know it's
split up there we'll try to edit it as
best as we can and then of course my
brother ksrt comment through man
dropping the knowledge gems breaking
down and seeing me with precision and
then of course give it that good Ally
steam deck love at the end in the
handheld scene where can the fine people
find you what you got going on sir
oh I will first and foremost say oh yeah
yeah of course here we go five dollars
move on to Sega it's his choice okay
okay yeah of course of course yeah no I
I appreciate your brothers inviting me
this it's always great to to be on this
show I will I have said it many places
and I will say it here my favorite
podcast on Sundays when you guys are not
on I'm I'm I'm beside myself when you
have an eight-hour joint my wife is
looking at me with the side eye cause I
can't take my hand off
please
no but thank you guys so much for having
me it's always always always a pleasure
to be here with you guys um gaming
Circle podcast uh TKO Sante on Twitter
Xbox please all those places you want to
find me we have been blessed with
awesome guests I think next week will be
another awesome question we got the IOP
the ILP might know something about we
would you know it's it's not confirmed
not confirmed yet we'll see we'll see
but IOP might appreciate that all right
so I'm putting it channeling it in the
thing um can I find what time is the
game and that is 10 a.m Eastern Standard
today on Saturday morning it is it is a
little it's a little bit a little bit
early for something but you know
depending on the guests we sometimes we
can we can move things around a little
bit but no it's always fun we're getting
a lot a lot more viewers a lot more
folks checking us out I see a lot of
friendly faces that check us out as well
so I I cannot I cannot sing my
appreciation more I appreciate you guys
always always you know supporting all of
that so uh you won't see me on here
you'll see me in your chat next week
because I'm always here I appreciate you
brother the support is tremendous and
then just to see your guys growth has
been amazing to see I try to sneak in
when I can and bro I really love the
discussion it's very intelligent
discussions like you have fun but it's
really cool you know what I'm saying and
keep up the good work but I love to see
it man I see my man ham Solo in there
gaming I see you in there what's going
on brother Saloon salute the ever born I
love what you guys got going on Salute
the Bluetooth for forgiving Brothers on
platform you know what I'm saying
absolutely as well he he will always be
no one will ever be able to talk down
the booth yeah
was longer than IOP this week that's the
new normal it was just crazy it was just
wild I don't know how the heck that
happened I apologize
it was about five hours or something
yeah they was out of control no doubt
though I guess I should love that attic
had to dip a little bit early for Hold
Us Down and then please say some love to
Lord solve again and my boy kaibatsu
going through it with a loss in the
family truly legit flood that timeline
hit him some love you know what I'm
saying again what they going through
right now because I know he wanted to be
here Lord King
bro you had the you had the bastards
fight they they came in here ready to
Pelt stones and thought it was going to
be a sacrifice but but you Rose up and
you you inspired a whole people say it
showed up people were like they got the
glow they playing you got the touch all
the inspirational music came out you
said you standing on your square and the
community is Friday because I'm the only
one that's keeping it a buck A lot of
these dudes like to you know ride off
the coattails when it's good you know
it's it's always great
to ride with somebody when they win it
um it's that's that's the best time
right you guys feel now the best time is
when that guy looks over when
everybody's deserted him and are you
standing there
I was the one that gave Phil his name
factual I was the one that was dead when
dude was like I don't I dudes I Know
That Rock with him was standing there
saying I don't know about this guy good
point that rock with him good point
that I was like nah B watch your mouth
he's the one no you had to check me
because I was coming with Matthew Peter
Morris man I was I was right yeah yeah
I'm still Peter Moore but I mean Phil's
my guy don't get me wrong much love to
feel but you know I'm a bias yeah so he
was like yeah
I said you know he's about he's about
the praise that I'm about to give him I
don't give praise to men easy pause
um but this but this dude right here and
and I see y'all now y'all thought that
was the death blow
um
y'all thought that was uh
the the final count that he's gonna take
he was gonna take the knee the CMA was
gonna be it no man I watched all Rocky
films I'm about a real hero I'm I'm a
Holyfield fan
I ain't hearing no Bell
so when it's over then you're gonna see
me bending me okay it's not over respect
and and when this dude lands that
Haymaker and your champ starts to wobble
and his knees start to shaking he starts
to he starts to buckle under the stress
and he looks at you and he tells you
remember what I said I was gonna do to
you
what y'all did was y'all making a beat
stronger than what he actually really is
you're hyping him up and he's gonna get
to that point where he's Gonna Knock You
smooth the hell out
what happens and it still goes through
you and it become that monster that
y'all didn't want him to be okay I
remember each and every last one of you
dudes that say I didn't like Call of
Duty anyway
I remember each and every last one of
you dudes it was like I don't care about
the deal the deal can go through fall
like here but was Champion it as soon as
it got blocked as soon as it got blocked
it came up your king where's your knees
they were scared don't be in your mouth
when the deal go through
all right so put some barbecue sauce on
my knees and take your teeth out cause
you're gonna get this meat you're gonna
get this thing
if it ain't over I I don't quit
I'm not fake so I'm still riding with
Phil Dominus Maximus really expensive
the name ain't gonna be broken into
nothing
um I want them to become Genghis Khan on
you
I want you to look over in Terror and
what he did because I've seen how soft
y'all are
flagged as soon as it get rough
and I gotta respect Jim Jim went out
there with his snitching ways what did I
tell you the Mount Rushmore snitches I'm
telling you oh no that's more
helping him the meek is the most
cowardly he is Loki
stop
he he
a master of Illusion
but I say this and I'm always going to
say this if Sean Laden was in place this
deal would have been done already it
took a beast like gym I
a dude that you know his spine is wiggly
you got a little tail and a little nose
about to cut throat with the cadaver
yeah I'm telling you that dude does what
he got to do to get where he's at I see
what he Consolidated Japan and took away
your Studios that you loved remember
that he folded them up when he went to
the EU mimic psychnosis he closed that
stuff down he closed Studios down he
Consolidated and he moved the war over
the EU
I respect you dude
so when they get your Pelt it's gonna be
the best pelt in the business oh still
coming for your Pelt shout out to
Littlefield running through and he's the
young squabbler I respect him Odin got
his back all right he riding you heard
it here first Lord addict is back to
help us out on any Final Super chats we
may have missed because we missed solved
very much but uh yeah me and my girl
went out for ice cream there we go
salute to you and your ice cream
oh my God
you had too much fun with that but uh
let me go what we got
are you still pulling them up
um did you read any since I've been gone
yeah I read the probably the last couple
but it's probably a few before that that
um you know I what you call it that I
definitely missed
I got up to the sagging nut sack I got
this thing I'm gonna just read them all
just before I'll let you know
let me read the ones that I know for a
fact I read okay
um
I read that one normal people I read
Jada both of them are red
uh slo-mo with the fight out super chat
if y'all getting treated like second
glass citizens go where Xbox values your
opinion on PC nope that's good no we
didn't really missed that one
two dollar Super Chat from TSW uh tsws
gaming doesn't that the S have more than
120 frames second games than PS5 yeah
doesn't the S have more 120 frames in
the PS5 yeah believe that is true yes we
got a five dollar subscribe from JW I
don't want a new deal I want to block
you merger Jim Ryan Jim Ryan is the goat
he said that he said that to Brad Sands
face and make good on that problem
I love that I want you to stick with
them and I want you I want to see you
next week and for the next coming week
so I want you to run I want you to hide
I want you to stick around when your
deal go through
I want your knees so you say JJ them
ain't mad enough to pop up here on IOP
if that deal goes through when the deal
was looking like it was going through
nobody was talking you ain't see nobody
outside me no more I remembered y'all I
forgot I forgot y'all still existed
until until you pop up you're like okay
I was like oh you're still alive
I see I see yeah man stick around
from Cowboy PS guys are short-sighted
ABK chose to sell after Vanguard didn't
sell well and the continued drop in
mau's I don't know what that is monthly
activities Oh okay monthly active users
ABK has said uh has said depending on
Call of Duty it's not sustainable ABK
could very well fade in a decade
he's saying in the long run he doesn't
know if they could survive or not from
Jada
MMA UK clearly stated
that Microsoft is signing up for
everybody is not detailed enough and
gave Microsoft 100 of the pot instead of
current industry standard 30 percent
okay
but if Tony would do it you'd be out
here get him get him sorry
got a 10 super trap from gamer by choice
I care about the deal because this has
wide reaching implications to companies
Beyond gaming wanting to merge imagine
if companies pull out of the industry
because they feel they cannot grow
well uh you know we're not we're not
going into any of these two dollar super
trap from Harkey shiny the stream is
being blocked more than the APK yeah
factual action Khan is on me because I'm
speaking facts two dollar Super Chat
from gamer by choice Microsoft entrusted
with UK security Cloud nope
why not super trap from a heart uh
Dragonheart Yobe Phil Spencer
is Hulkamania he's tired of the of being
nice it's time to bring out the
Hollywood Spencer and create the
NWO for Life brother I think that
happened five dollar super shot from Jay
Rembert King is Right Microsoft needs to
stop being nice the nice guy at least
when it comes to Sony anyway
two dollar Super Chat from uh ghost uh
Spartan ghost 17. Phil burned the ships
grab the shields we going
five dollar super trap from Nintendo uh
the dawn otaku Phil Spencer is Kang at
the end of Loki and the CMA is uh Sylvia
effectively turning him into the Cocker
yup five dollar Super Chat from uh
from second nut sack
dude hold up hold up uh five dollar
Super Chat from Reggie mobile9 salute to
the Lord's exodusly three-part show I
agree with King I think it's all delay
tactics in the end Microsoft will win
two no Super Chat from Spartan go 17.
Sony will be selling cartridges when
Dustin settless yo they but you for for
someone with this bad news can you
really allow these he rised them up he
got the masses on the squids
he just can't just like delivered that
speech that's that that you have when
you're like in The Lord of the Rings
listen listen I don't want them ever to
have a mustard seed heart we don't do
soft talk Sundays here our hearts don't
pump Kool-Aid we are Spartans and we
don't ever fold at the first sign of
trouble don't ever forget that Spartans
ride today yeah respect respect it's
fine okay now we got the sagging nut
sack the super cats five I don't
understand the sudden goal post move
from quality to new cloud gaming what
changes Google snitching too wow and we
got a 10 super chat from sack and
nutsack uh
let's be clear let's be honest cloud
gaming is nowhere near perfect one we
need someone like Microsoft to step up
and make it better without them I don't
see cloud gaming going anywhere ten
dollar Super Chat from Mario 187 do you
think Xbox should make the series s into
a piece
I think I think we caught it but I just
want to make sure no there's still more
okay oh from what you've read yeah I
remember that one reading from that
point because there's two ever borns
there's a bunch of ever boards we did I
think that we caught up there because
those are the ones we did cool and
there's a member chat that y'all missed
that I put in the in the uh in the in
the chat here okay okay there's a
membership inside
thank you
Auto remember chat and I think Stitch
was like yeah we missed his member chat
but yeah I I have I have stitches here
okay cool okay we got a 41 month members
from Stitch if the EU passes the deal
the UK could lose cloud gaming also the
decision just hurt uh the decision just
her every other cloud service that was
going to benefit from this deal thoughts
yeah yeah I feel that you know um
Microsoft handed out those deals and you
know working with the CMA and what they
put forth uh was a benefit for Microsoft
but at the end of the day they use that
to uh you know like basically hold it
against them
um with enough petitions and enough
people you know appealing with Microsoft
they have a whole bunch of people that
can benefit from it so
um I think the appeal process will go in
Microsoft's favor
we shall see but yeah that's I think
this is a giant flaming L
this is like
this is like Microsoft mailing their own
L to them they're not getting anything
you know what king just because I love
this deal to go through if I'm wrong I'm
willing to give you my knees I don't
I don't want your knees I don't I don't
want you to be flip-flopping no more
yeah I want you to pledge I want you to
Pledge Your Heart to Microsoft
how about I give you your knees back
listen I already grew knees back I'm
moving
you got me generator okay yeah my knee's
been back weeks ago
the thing is this
I want you to understand you will not be
tolerated in this space we gotta get up
we gotta get I gotta talk to graphics
for soft talk because some some lips
Whispering very softly that we don't
need no more soft talk Sundays we gotta
walk away from that fair enough but look
that's all I got unless anybody got
anything else added you got anything
else before we done get up all out of
here
[Laughter]
oh we're bleeding
I feel like an entire entire government
saying no is not the drop of a hat no
and you have one person outside that say
yes EU got us this is this is an
independent person that decides to do
this now when the EU says now we with
what this independent dude was talking
about you can work over here
don't give them it I cannot wait for
them not to get it
for their offices to be bombarded with
why can't we have what are y'all doing
and then when everybody on that team
decided to change the region that their
Xboxes for and their PlayStation is from
and they abandoned the region when all
the little lights go out the region
we'll populate someplace else and they
actually have it
yeah you the cause and I want them I
want I want I want Miss Khan to go over
there and try to figure out what the CMA
don't want to talk to her
and there you have it
so look we will catch you guys next
Sunday absolutely funny show oh I'm sure
next Sunday is gonna be one crazy let's
see what happens we got more stuff
cooking go check that out and again make
sure you go subscribe to my brother ks9
to the gaming Circle podcast and that's
all I got everybody enjoy your Sunday
and thanks for rocking with us
[Music]
thank you